and it says that it's got planning
permission already granted
so planning permission is already in
place now is that a good thing or a bad
thing
it's neither good nor bad
it just means
that some of the profits already been
taken
because a lot of the profit in
development is in getting planning
so if you find sites that have already
got planning that's okay but it means
you're not going to make as much profit
as you would if you're the person that
got the panic does that make sense guys
okay so this has got development site
you're going to be able to build
four houses
it's currently 1.165 million
what do you say the end value will be
[Music]
350 400
[Music]
each right well it looks very
interesting i'd need to obviously spend
a bit more time doing due diligence
before i could say if it was good or bad
but great finds give the ladies a hand
give them a hand
all right anyone got anything better
naomi has these guys have you've got
something better you've got something
better name you're very excited what is
it
one million profit what is it already
got planning permission
where is it
has he got planning already
sure i i like it when it's not got
planning
is it very conservative all right go on
give me the postcode
cn1
cm1
3d
3bo
okay
i'm just going to take off the land
um
as a house
all right let's have a little looks here
this
is that it
oh okay so what are you thinking
okay
all right
development opportunity chelmsford
um hasn't got planning
all right come on up the front come on
the front come on guys i'll give him a
massive hand
all right good so
firstly go on pictures on this deal why
is this better than the other two that
we've just seen
[Music]
275 300 profit
okay so you've got this house and this
house in itself it says that it needs a
little bit of work is that correct yes
now i like this this has got um another
day and a half before the closing date
finishes for all offers so it's going to
be just a case of higher higher offer
there's no planning permission for
applied for so they've never gone for
planning before um but pre-app is
available okay good
so you're thinking
to refurb it make it beautiful but then
also
to build a house here
at the bottom of the garden so guys do
you think that's that could be possible
yes or no
well there is access isn't it because
there's a road here
so if you were to build here a house
here
people would come down this road and
then they'd be able to go to the house
so you need to
um obviously need to get planning
permission you need to drop the kerb and
there's a few things that you need to do
that's all normal but would it be
fitting with the area well i think it
probably would be
it's a bit
house there would look
would look fine it would look fitting i
really like this one as well
tell these guys why your deal's
best because it's a great opportunity
well it's the
why you you need to be looking at them
because these houses this is another
thing i look at right this is on for 600
000
let's have a look at how much the
general houses are going for that they
might have put
put it as a premium
[Music]
okay
yeah i can see that because look even
though the little crappy terraced houses
are going for three two five but houses
that look similar
i mean this is four two five
yeah three taps went for 535
so you probably got a gross development
value with two detached houses of about
a million quid
right
this is where we lift your due diligence
but if you bought that for 600
it would probably cost 150 grand
to build
another house so you're talking about
750 all in i can see i have to do more
due diligence but why you could easily
make a few hundred thousand pounds clean
profit from this one day i can see it
happening subject to planning and
further due diligence do you guys like
it
so here's what we're gonna do um if you
guys can stand at the corner of the
stage together i'll take the mic at the
corner stage my sheffield guys could you
could you guys come and could you just
stand just here right here
and then my land ladies come on up come
on up you can stand in the middle and
here's what's going to happen so the the
winning team are going to receive a cash
prize of 100 pounds and i do have 100
pounds in my pocket i got two
crisp 50 pound notes now
guess what's more valuable than the 50
pound note what's more bible is the
lesson yes or no
i mean you know
ryan paid me three grand for a dinner
and then went on i made 300 000 pounds
on his first deal so this is not a lot
of money this is just for fun however
i'm gonna give the money to
the uh the the group or the partnership
that gets the loudest cheer in a moment
so let's just refresh ourselves on the
deal so we've got this deal you just
seen
then with the ladies they found the land
they like the the big piece of land
and then our sheffield guy oh i did like
that
okay so we've got sheffield have found
this this
then we've got the chelmsford property
and then we've got the land so um
sheffield is this
the land opportunity
and chelmsford do you all remember what
the projects are yes or no
now i'm going to give you each
uh 30 seconds to tell everybody why your
deal was the best then we're going to
vote in form of cheering so
ladies you can go first
all right amazing so give them all a
hand
all right give them all a hand
all right so
chalmersford
land
and sheffield so when i say when i point
to them you've got to cheer up against
the loudest cheer is going to win the
hundred pounds cash prize so
sheffield
[Applause]
lands
[Applause]
was probably the quietest chair so well
done on the exercise go and grab a c
give them a big hand
uh it's between
it's between the sh
let me remind you of the deals it's
between the sheffield deal which is this
one
and the challenge for deal
which is this one
okay so this is chelmsford
nice
nice like it and this is sheffield
so we'll do one last time see who gets
the loudest chair so for sheffield chair
now
sound was fun
i'm gonna say i think just about just
about
the winner is
sheffield
all right well done
well done
hi i'm monday uh we've just come to the
crash course today um the development
crash course uh just uh we're trying to
find deals
based all over the country and we've
found a deal just now
yeah my name is george um from
southampton um like andy just said we've
come down today um to find deals
development deals uh different obviously
styles different uh opportunities uh we
managed to find one today on stage and
out of all the groups uh we got voted
the best opportunity yeah yeah and
before coming today before coming here
today did you guys know how to find how
to find these opportunities or
no we didn't know uh we've just been on
right move and just looked at lots of uh
opportunities on there and from samuel
lager's help uh we've just been able to
find a really great deal uh that would
become a very good uh develop
development
opportunity brilliant what was the deal
yeah it took us through what was it the
deal was a two-bedroom house with
potential of building
another house on the side the
two-bedroom house could be demolished
itself
and built into four-bedroom house
just lots and lots of potential so the
potential of uh building two
two four-bedroom houses yeah and to
anybody watching who wants to get into
development what you know what would you
say to them
in terms of this event just start
looking and yeah i'd say get yourself
down to the course i mean i'm on
advanced training as well and the
academy and it's really helped me um
development side as well i say get down
to the course and see how it is i mean
samuel is a great guy lovely ldg and
yeah yeah i mean it's a different ball
game all together really um obviously
development's a lot bigger a lot more
profit in it
but yeah i'll get down to the free the
free training so you feel and then you
want to invest into your favorite
education
[Music]
just if you're
interested in property just come and see
one of the
crash courses and some of your leads and
just there's just a lot of potential to
be
ready to become financially free
get comfortable being uncomfortable
[Music]